[Music]
[Applause]
real hollywood story
chippendale rescue rangers the show that
defined the generation and turned two
unknown chipmunks into international
superstars
[Music]
but his success took chippendale to new
heights to many more seasons of the
rescue rangers we were living the dream
dancing the roger rabbit with roger
rabbit
no one ever imagined
it could all come crashing down
[Music]
torn by vanity you look different hey
it's no secret i had the cgi surgery
done
consumed by temptation my love of cheese
got the best of me i just love it so
much more please
more please
is it possible that two living legends
are destined to reunite
i'm thinking reboot nobody wants a
reboot
it's the rescue ranger you need a
disguise or something grab the first
thing you can
[Music]
rescue rangers 2.0
[Music]
this place looks weird remember that
animation style where everything looked
real but nothing looked right who are
you
are you talking to us obviously but it
looks like you're talking to that window
it actually looks like i'm looking right
at you okay look at my eyes looking
right at your eyes
[Music]